als sich alexander wang oder breit in
haiti gebracht habe hätte ich mich
träumen lassen sich ja selber landen
würde
das geht über nacht blitzschnell
meine lunge ist zusammengebrochen und
ich habe 48 stunden mit jedem atemzug
dafür gekämpft nicht ins koma zu feiern
auf dem tief station der charité
professor eckhard dass ich es geschafft
habe
das insofern wichtig war weil ich kenne
ich die deutschen zahlen aber zum
beispiel im ausland usa sterben 60
prozent der menschen die ins künstliche
koma genommen werden also die
wahrscheinlichkeit zu sterben als wieder
aufzuwachen ist wesentlich größer
deshalb haben wir alles getan obwohl ich
mehrmals unter der grenze war und
mehrmals ins koma gesetzt werden sollte
habe ich dagegen gekämpft und ist es mir
gelungen weil es sich ein herausragendes
fachpersonal mit krankenschwestern ärzte
leute die von allen stationen sich haben
hierher versetzen lassen
in den zwei wochen wo ich hier bin hat
sich die zahl der betten verdreifacht
mit mittlerweile ausnahmezustand die
bundeswehr muss helfen also diese
statistischen annahmen der tagesschau wo
man zieht wir haben noch kapazität
intensivbetten das täuscht denn es gibt
kein fachpersonal mehr
das heißt wenn ich dieses fachpersonal
nicht gehabt hätte würde ich jetzt im
koma liegen und gerade heute hat zum
beispiel meine schwester marina winder
ich hier betreut gesagt wir sind am
limit
es geht nicht mehr weiter es geht
logistisch weiter ist wer mehr betten
geschaffen
aber es gibt nicht mehr pfleger es gibt
nicht mehr ärzte das heißt ich war ein
absoluter gegner das locker aus dem
frühjahr die intensivstation waren leer
aber jetzt haben wir absolut keine
andere wahl bei all den diskussionen ich
von der politik höre ich die
unterstützung der pflege und der ärzte
und was noch am wichtigsten ist
alle kraftanstrengungen müssten sich ein
konzentrieren den impfstoff so schnell
wie möglich zu besorgen
denn sonst bleibt das wesen stop and go
wir werden dieses infektionsgeschehen
nicht in den griff bekommen
ich bin das nächste impfstoff so schnell
wie möglich her